Hey, what do you want to be? You
can be anything here.
This is Eide
Academy. It's a school for kids who want to play an active role in the virtual world.
Every day, many students here
take various classes in order to become who they want to be.  I want to be
like my idol Kizuna Ai-chan, so I'm
working hard every day,
but because I'm
acting on my own momentum, I often
fail.But I want to connect with many people, so I
'm working hard without giving up.This
girl is my classmate Chris, and she's really cute.  She's an
amazing girl who can easily learn dancing just by watching her once. She seemed to be very interested in me for some reason. Her
face was too close to Miraku's performance. She was
sparkling. She's
very good at singing and dancing, and is a popular virtual
artist.  He works harder than anyone else, and is very
dependable.I want to
become the perfect virtual artist that I aim to be.He's also very good at
rhythm, and he can use
anything he does to improve his activities as a virtual artist.I have to
follow his example.
This girl is quiet and quiet,
but she
is a kind person who supports us well.The unit made up of me, Mirak, and
Chris Noel Lizquon is
Bust Live.We have different personalities and personalities,
but that's why we
move forward together.  There must be a world that can be seen with
friends. I want to connect more and more with my friends as I aim to become a virtual artist like Kizuna Ai. Kizuna no
Ariru will be broadcast in 2023
[Music]